what did we learn from kamala harris's
tenure well we learned that she's
incredibly manipulative that she will
use people to get ahead and then she
will ditch them at the first available
opportunity as we'll see she did this to
joe biden as well
and she will ditch him at first
available opportunity as well too
we know that she is perfectly willing to
use the auspices of government in order
to achieve particular goals
she's willing to be authoritarian in her
use of government and she's threatened
to be incredibly authoritarian if ever
she became president
during this last campaign she repeatedly
talked about how she was going to
overthrow the boundaries of
constitutional government
like all the time she said openly that
she would give congress 100 days to act
on guns
and then if congress did not act on guns
then she would immediately
use executive action to act on guns so
this is her openly threatening to
violate the constitution if congress
doesn't do
there is no clause in the constitution
by the way that says if congress doesn't
do
what the president wants the executive
branch shall have the powers to simply
declare the law
there's nothing in the constitution like
that but as we'll see kamala harris does
not give two good dams about the
constitution
because that's who she is here was
kamala harris in open debate
saying that she'd give congress a
hundred days tax on guns then she'd just
do it herself
upon being elected i will give the
united states congress 100 days
to get their act together and have the
courage to pass reasonable gun safety
laws and if they fail to do it
then i will take executive action and
specifically what i will do
is put in place a requirement that for
anyone who sells more than five guns a
year
they are required to do background
checks when they sell those guns
amazing amazing so she's just gonna do
it herself and then when she was asked
about this in open debate
right joe biden was like um that's
unconstitutional commonwealth like
there's a lot of stuff you can't just do
as president of the united states and
kamala is like well yes we can
hyena like joker laugh okay so by the
way
like it's i guess it's good that she was
cast as vp because otherwise she would
have been the heir apparent for for the
joker part
right jared leto was out already so the
next suicide squad would have been
kamala harris laughing with that crazy
caesar romero kind of giggle here she
was
trying to explain to joe biden that the
constitution is hacked it no longer
matters and joe biden's standing there
but i remember the constitution i was
there when they when they wrote it i've
been ignoring it for
and then he fell asleep here this was
from a democratic debate you can't do it
by executive order any more than trump
can do things
when he says he can do it by executive
order does the vice president have a
point there
some things you can many things you
can't let's let the senator answer
well i mean i would just say hey joe
instead of saying no we can't let's say
yes we can
let's be constitutional you got to come
yes we can't
yeah looking forward to a lot of that
looking forward to a lot of that get
ready
you got a lot of that that crazy laugh
yeah good stuff happening there so she's
an authoritarian who can laugh crazily
so
that's exciting stuff by the way she
also supports packing the supreme court
so that's good
definitely somebody who is a pragmatic
moderate according to the new york times
harris told politico quote we are on the
verge of a crisis of confidence in the
supreme court
we have to take this challenge head on
everything is on the table to do that
so she joined with and kirsten
gillibrand and elizabeth warren
saying that she might consider packing
at the courts she's definitely a
moderate guys
definitely definitely moderate did you
know that every like on this video
creates one additional leftist tier
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity hit the like button